das alles unserem team jetzt noch hier
sind 15 leute hat mir wieder begonnen
dort ich hab's services geht und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
verrückte aktion mit der community
wir sind jetzt wieder mit 15 leuten hier
in 64 es übrigens erst mal in die mitte
kommt mit guten preis als wert bin
leider der mitte bleiben damit einfach
alle in der mitte bleiben sie direkt
diese gehört dieser nächster zu uns
nehmen excellence zu uns die ärzte waren
es die gäste mit dieser wechselt nicht
zu uns okay und luca cmc etr jpm us
select nice wer jetzt bei uns okay
erstmal will ok ihr habt nicht alle
ausgestattet um 66 nein diese extra key
vorne zurück
das verrät er hat sich in unseren reihen
eingeschlichen ich habe ihn okay
woher genau wie hinterher ich war west
freut wer ist feind
das heißt es produziere glaub ich okay
leute lasst das zwar lief mit ihr
versammeln dahin ist einer hier hier
hier
xerox auch in honig sind ihr laufen hier
drauf hatte ich mal den gut gefällt
haben greifen mal als erster anderen
rennen voraus sehr schön
du kannst du schon mal passiert ob
bauern alle mods youtube oder so
vergeben könne
wenn du gar nicht nur bis ja es kann
kann ich viele leute drin habe ich geh
mal 50 30
okay ihr lang genau wusste mich gerne
gehabt oder sowas und wieder muss man
fast auf den sound ist ein
wenn wir so vielen leuten woche hier
heute physisch für die gäste nein nein
nein nein ich komme ich dran
ich habe aufkommen ist so eine
lächerliche range es ist richtig im kopf
einkommen von der luft holstein gehört
kam ein christian rein politisch
motiviert
dieser punkt wird zu 15 junge ok hat
noch ein bekommt amigo schreiben sie auf
ok
meist dauert es dann okay okay das sind
das sind nicht alle hier weil sie
kurzfristig ab und kommen dort arbeiten
und so weiter und so fort
ich habe da oben pannen gesehen das sind
gegner kein schwert wird kein schwert
also wird man erst mal kurz mal zu mir
kommen als originale quittiert hatte
okay ich habe viele schwerter junge
täter nein es gibt diese 31 der 2 für
unsere brüder der geholt
okay aber jetzt da wie vor schwer falle
ok ich glaub mir aber ein paar sagt zack
zack
vielleicht doch generell mal alles was
ich gut gebrauchen kann okay hier hier
hier zeigt das könnt ihr haben so möchte
ich mal jung wie viele einfach darum
gehen war hand aus bachern riesig was
google jeden agiert man diesen gegnern
jungen positiv hat sich so kostizyn
restaurierter 6 ich hatte einfach
geradeaus kann ich auch so
ich muss ein bisschen mitarbeiten müssen
darauf konzentrieren dass ich nicht die
ganze bleiberecht gesagt hätte was ich
sagen wollte
danke dass die letzte folge so gut
positives angst bekommen hat es
vielleicht google habe ich voll gefreut
ruckzuck auf 1000 likes und hause nike
sind jetzt in meiner größe noch nicht
alltäglich deswegen frage ich mich
direkt vor freund und wird euch gefällt
klar gerne bei mir gefährlich auch dann
macht mir das sowieso noch mal jetzt
thomas daniel keller plattling
er bleibt aber hängen sieht man in
zukunft will jetzt natürlich weiß der
praxis später fing das nehme ich mit
ich will dass mein buch also
hundertprozentig clean ist als er sich
irgendwann mal hängen bleibt
auch hier ist aber da habe ich gehört
ein aktiver verein mit oder corpus von
1,4 jetzt endlich mal ein kleines
bisschen range level aber gebt euch das
mal man leute ich glaube dass jetzt der
zeitpunkt näher zurückblicken müssen
ganz ehrlich das ist formal mir dass es
mal an und leistet kann den klägern
brechen lassen
habt ihr habt ihr doch es steckt viel
ereignis sein geht nicht da bin ich da
nicht da er hat ein faktor jungen sie
dieses verhalten
das war klar hatte einfach mitgenommen
ohne wird sie müssen erstmal items für
unsere gefallenen brüder
wir haben keine vorliebe ausschütten
können deswegen ganz ehrlich einfach
hier aus respekt was er mir noch das
kann ich es noch geben einfach für alle
lieben und kampf
rund 60 hertz str wir haben mit 15
leuten angefangen
alter schwede die jungen sind das alles
unserem team jetzt hier sind
ich habe essen ja nichts aus einem
schwert risiko ja privat ich kenne
locken immer das thema das sehr schön
habt ihr feld der herren feld anderen
hätten es für mich hat jetzt natürlich
riesig sind raus nehmen
ok alte 15 leute hat mir wieder begonnen
deutlicher worte packen die heute
begrüßen können und dann folgt mir lokal
wird keine handeln ich habe eine mega
ich kenne ich kann nicht einen
doppelgänger gedrückt so so und dann ich
habe hier sind acker ausgenommen fest
wenn nichts ergebnis wir müssen es jetzt
für unsere gefallenen brüdern diese
holen leute
wir rechnen für die gefallenen
eskalieren kampf hätte ich schmeiße
sagst welche wie gesagt wir kennen keine
getränke ausschütten das will ich das
machen
ich muss gar an einen moment auf die
youtube space party berlin denken hatte
video days ja ja ja ich weiß dass ich
meinen leuten die dem gebäude sind
gewollt funktioniere einfach weiß hier
kommt eine auch hier irgendwo
nirgendwo haben sich in diesem gebäude
verkaufen wir müssen ganz oft gefallen
nein du wirst schon zusammen schaffen
wir werden alle drei städte sagt mich so
was die richtung sind die vielleicht
nicht mehr gebäude und seines sports
okay das mal machen wenn man sie gefällt
mir nicht meinte ihr könnt euch runter
mal ein bisschen anders runter klappt
sogar erst jetzt gab das jetzt hat das
und sagen okay es ist da jungs com mit
42 besser zurück
die offensichtlich glaubt der experte
damit die achse warte erstmal recht ich
bin offensichtlich hatte derselben ist
wenn er schon spam
das war ein gericht hatte dann noch viel
vor da schielt man geht die ganze band
einfach wollten aber es tut es
vielleicht muss man sein
unter den ultras war irgendwie auf ein
ganz am anfang als alle in der gruppe
gelaufen sind war einer der mich direkt
getötet
so groß kann sich immer einschleichen
konzentrieren
ich hab' ich habe ein
respekt machen es geben wenn ihr konzept
für vielfalt und so könnt ihr euch den
bogen geht an private gibt mir keine
mogelei nichts von euch nehmen hatte
massig sein dass dinge lernt erschwert
sie spielt einfach aus
ich wollte ein haus geholt wurde
ich laufe einfach nach dem kompost
diesen kurs genommen scheiße aber heute
welche runde gefeiert wir gerne auch
noch unterlassen so wie es ist und es
immer sehr viele die nase